and finally new rule white liberals have
to start listening to me when I tell
them you can't be more offended than the
victim it happened again last week when
presidential contender Andrew yang faced
criticism because he said that SNL
should not have fired comedian Shane
Gillis of a racist comments Gillis made
about Asians that's when the internet
did what it does best and deemed yang a
racist for for not being offended
because if he wasn't offended well
someone had to be there was a study done
last year where people were asked to
rate their feelings about various races
and white liberals were the only group
that has a bias against themselves they
want to hang out only with people who
are not them that's like your mother
preferring the neighbors kids there is a
weird self-loathing going on among white
liberals and it's not helping anyone
lifting up those who society has cheated
or forsaken that's liberalism hating all
things white is just tedious virtue
signaling you look like Justin
Timberlake and bad teacher hate slavery
so so much series the worst if I could
go back in time and undo slavery I would
I hate it
the answer to mass incarceration to stop
putting undeserving blacks in prison not
to put more white people in Twitter jail
every thought needs a disclaimer now the
other day I heard a guy say I realized
I'm only speaking as a white male and I
acknowledge our tragic history of
oppression but you left your lights on
look white privilege is real and yes you
have some advantages for being white but
you also have some disadvantages many of
you were born with a terrible
personality
[Applause]
that's not item nasca that's I'll fire
the director but you don't need to
advertise it what's with the I'm
embarrassed to be white subgenre on the
internet I'm finding myself constantly
embarrassed to be white I'm watching
tall girl I've never been so embarrassed
to be white retweet if you're
embarrassed to be what Jesus [ __ ]
rosanna arquette tweeted I'm sorry I was
born white and privileged it disgusts me
and I feel so much shame exactly you
think it's hard being a black man in a
white man's world try being a white
woman who feels bad about you being a
black man in the white one of us chose
to be born white not even ed Sheeran so
just stop because you know what might be
the worst part of white shame you bore
the [ __ ] out of black people at parties
you meet black people and say things
like Black Panther was so meaningful to
me no it wasn't it wasn't a cultural
milestone for you I have taken an
informal sampling among some black folks
I know and the consensus seems to be
awareness yes is great white people
certainly should acknowledge they've had
it easier go of it but black folks are
not asking White's to always be
flatulating themselves because it makes
everything awkward all right
it puts the burden on black people to
absolve you it's really it's it's really
asking black people to again do
something for you forgive me absolve me
recognize that I'm one of the good white
people Jesus heaven black people
suffered enough slavery Jim Crow now now
I got to make something up II feel
better about himself as a black friend
of mine said and I quote I'm doing I I
don't need your pity
here's my question how many white
liberals would pay actual reparations
real money taken out of your paycheck
every week if you really feel this bad
about the whole race thing and being
white is really this toxic for society
let's tax it let's tax whiteness a hunky
tax will do it like carbon offsets will
calculate your exact level of white
lameness and then church then charge you
a Caucasian offset fee based on a mean
percentage of household income indexed
to the net not gross national product an
average with the Consumer Price Index we
will come up with just the right dollar
figure to offset the exact amount of you
being a [ __ ] loser a lame white loser
now pay up you [ __ ] white piece of
[ __ ] you [ __ ] worm I mean that's what
you want to hear isn't it isn't it
maggot you [ __ ] you want to be told that
a disgusting piece of white [ __ ] you are
you white piece of [ __ ]
look
in conclusion I just want to say America
has done a lot of good things and a lot
of bad ones and the number one bad one
with no close second is racism it's a
sorry history and we're not done with it
and yet black and white increasingly
intermingle we get to the finish line on
race by just being with each other more
we don't need awkward we need laughing
with each other finding out what's good
about each other befriending
intermarrying enjoying somebody's
company without thinking every minute
I'm with a person of color you're with a
person
and you are not uncool just because
you're white and it is not a crime to
know all the words to Sweet Caroline
you